Right, this diagram you have to remember, this
diagram is just explaining what
will be your spermatogonia, what will it do, it will do
division, it will do mitosis, it will make primary
spermatocyte, right then this primary spermatocyte will make
your meiosis one, it will
make haploid secondary spermatocyte and then
this is the secondary spermatocyte.  Then what does meiosis do to you,
what does it do to you, will it create sperm
mated and these spur mated will do your
differentiated myogenesis and will get
converted into your haploid spermatozoa, okay
so this is your diagram of NCRT which is
very easy to remember.  ok for us